I only recently got the opportunity to
play through near automata and in a lot
of ways it lived up to the massive hype
it has received there are a million
things I could praise about this game
and in future videos I might do just
that if for any reason you watching this
video haven't played the game yet and
are thinking about it please do it is an
amazing experience and a brilliantly
designed video game but with all that
said in this video I'm not going to be
talking about how good of a game
automata is right now I want to talk
about my biggest problem with automata
and that is route B I need to be careful
in articulating my issue here because I
don't want to only present my problem as
a surface level one what I mean is that
my problem with route B is not just the
more common complaint that it is
repetitive although I think that
complaint is justified my issue is that
this repetitiveness can have the
opposite effect of which it was intended
for and this reversal of effect can
cause players to miss out on some very
important yet non required parts of the
game so if you haven't played automata
let me break it down there are two main
characters at the start of the game
Android's to B and 9s you start the game
as to B and after a while will
eventually reach ending a however there
are actually five main endings to the
game that you unlock in a linear fashion
as you progress after achieving ending a
you are given control of 9s at around
the same in-game time as when you
started with to B this is route B and
after playing it through you will get
ending B and after that keep playing and
you'll get ending C D and E and you let
properly be in the game however for this
video I don't care about all those
latter routes only route B I want to
talk about route B because unlike the
other routes B is essentially a repeat
of a route it covers the same game time
as route a and because a lot of rock a
includes to B and 9s together route B
has a lot of its events essentially copy
pasted over from route 8 I could end my
complaint here but that would be a bit
too basic of a qualm to make a whole
video about even though one of the more
common complaints against automata is
precisely this repetition and in defense
of our team one could quickly point to
the different combat styles respect
differences between 9s and to be
presentation of new information in route
P and the different side quests all is
evidence of distinction between routes a
and B and these are all valid points
granted the simplicity of the nine as
hacking can get a bit stale route B does
offer a lot of new information about the
story and world that changes how we see
and understand events that are shared
between the routes the little films
shown before each new zone and 9s his
own revelations as two examples of these
informational differences but I think
everyone could agree that route B is
repetitive to some extent it's an
integral part of the route
it was clearly designed with that
repetition in mind you're supposed to
repeat the events of Rock a but by
gaining better insight and understanding
or up B is supposed to take on its own
form I believe that this repetition has
a very specific purpose
I think Yoko taro and PlatinumGames
wanted this repetition to push the
player into exploring the many side
quests that are only available
throughout B if you're forced to replay
a significant portion of the game you'll
be yearning for something new to do to
combat the monotony and boredom of
replaying content ideally these new side
quests show up and offer the player the
perfect opportunity to rid themselves of
said monotony new missions that reveal
new information and offer new gameplay
scenarios or what people want to see as
they progress through the game and while
the main quest of route B does offer
some new information and insights it's
not quite enough to really get rid of
those negative feelings of boredom at
least it wasn't in my experience in a
perfect playthrough the player may start
to feel bored in route B but soon finds
all this new content story and gameplay
found in the side quests and quickly
forgets any of those feelings of
tediousness that is what I think was
intended for route B and hopefully
that's what happened for most people
considering the game was given such
outstanding reviews I'm assuming that
this was how most people experience the
game unfortunately though I did not have
this experience for me this repetition
worked in the opposite way instead of
pushing me to the side quests to break
up monotony it pushed me to rush through
the main quest and suffer much more rat
repetition than intended let me try to
explain why I think this happened after
starting about feet at the completely
new gameplay section with 9s I felt that
the whole route would be in that style
really emphasizing the time 9s was away
from to be to offer new gameplay however
I soon realized that a lot of the route
was actually covering the time spent
with 2b and this meant replaying
significant chunks of the game this
coupled with some time spent on basic
side quests like gathering materials for
the resistance camps shop keeps and
rebooting angles made me think that
route B was essentially a repeat of rap
a but with a couple new cinematics and
better insight into 9s is mine which
made me view rep D as something to get
over with as opposed to something to
really enjoy in its own right
I don't argue that things like those
short cinematics about the machines
weren't important or didn't help me
understand the game but they were not
nearly enough to differentiate route B
on their own especially because when I
first viewed them in the playthrough a
rowdy they were really confusing and I
was unsure of exactly what they meant it
wasn't until I really finished the game
and learn more about it that I got a
better understanding the feelings of
monotony and boredom descended upon me
with no adversaries to fight back
against them I didn't see the side
quests as the beacons of hope they were
meant to be see in rock 8 I completed a
good majority of the side quests they
were fun and written well and did a
great job of world-building but they
didn't feel like they included a lot of
key information that would drastically
improve or change my understanding of
the game they definitely helped to paint
a better picture of the universe I was
in and I did enjoy them but I didn't get
a feeling of weight and most of them and
that was totally ok they're side quests
after all I have the main quest to learn
key information so I don't need side
quests for that this meant that I didn't
give a huge amount of emphasis to the
importance of side quests and then in
route B when the main quests often
lacked new key information or at least
lacked what I could recognize as new key
information
I didn't know to prioritize the side
classes as a result I completed
drastically fewer side quests and was in
more of a rush to progress the main
quest and to get to a point where I
started getting new key information and
story progression this calls my route be
played through to suffer a lot I was
essentially deprived of a significant
amount of story information and world
context while having nothing to break up
the monotony inherent in route feat this
left me feeling underwhelmed once I
actually finished the entire game I was
somewhat upset that that was it I very
much think that my not so great
experience with the route be tainted my
overall appreciation of the game
especially when I first finished it
but then I saw some videos talking about
why people think automata is such a good
game and why it's so luck and through
this I was able to make a connection
that really let me understand and see a
Tomita and a new light I'll try to
explain this epiphany if I can call it
that the storytelling in automata is
very hands-off the game has a lot of
information and can get really confusing
for anyone that's part of the point
those really dedicated to understanding
the game can play through every quest
and read every bit of data to form a
clear picture of everything that
happened from the start of the game to
ending II those that aren't as dedicated
can still have a fun time and play
through the main parts of the game
they'll just be left with more questions
so here's the connection this is
actually a really similar method of
storytelling to that of Dark Souls a
method that I praised and loud 'add in
my video about how souls tells a story
so how could I get mad at automata for
doing the same thing that I loved one of
my favorite franchises doing once I'm
old this overfor that I started to
realize that what I disliked in automata
was that this hands-off approach kind of
backfired for me it wasn't an inherent
problem in the style just that the
implementation unfortunately missed the
mark in my case see there's one big
distinction between these games that I
need to bring up that opened up the
possibility for the bad time I had in
automata automata is a very story driven
game
whereas Dark Souls is much more gameplay
driven evidently using this hands-off
kind of storytelling for a story driven
game is dangerous so in all honesty I
don't think Dark Souls has very good
main stories they're generally fairly
basic and really not the focus of any of
games however I think that's fine as the
souls born games are not story driven
game they would no doubt be better if
they had good main stories but the games
can still be enjoyed in their entirety
with what stories they have souls games
focus much more on their world building
and even more on their gameplay than
they do their main stories they actually
tell a lot of their best stories through
the lore and through the lore is where
from software employs this hands-off
technique the lore of the souls universe
is complex riveting intriguing and
mysterious it lets those who really want
to figure out all the complex stories do
so through a lot of research and
dedication and others that don't want to
invest that kind of time in work don't
have to they can enjoy the game for what
it was primarily made for which is the
world in the gameplay and get a basic
understanding of the story and more and
if they want they can check out the lore
theories on forums and videos like those
I have made here is where I think the
main similarity lies between these two
games tying directly back to near and
why I said this method was dangerous
automatons focus is more so the
narrative than it is the gameplay using
the hands-off approach of storytelling
in a narrative based game means that
some people may miss out on valuable
parts of the main focus of the game the
narrative this is kind of how I felt
after finishing the game in Dark Souls
that wouldn't be a problem because its
main focus
it is gameplay not narrative if some
players lose out on the narrative it's
totally okay because none of them will
lose out on the gameplay which is the
game's main focus the game is still
delivering its main goal to every single
player but not Tommy - the focus is the
narrative and the hands-off approach
means some players might lose out on the
narrative this means players might lose
out on the main focus of the game which
is never something that
should have this allows for some players
although thankfully it seems like only a
minority to slip through the cracks so
to say and lose out on fully
experiencing the core identity of
automata this is my gripe with the game
that it gives the opportunity however
small for some people to miss out on
crucial parts of its main focus which as
I said I don't think any game should do
if I were to guess what the best fix for
this would be I would say add some of
the more impactful side quests to the
required missions group pretty simple
and I don't think it would ruin the flow
or the design philosophy of the game too
much it could still maintain the
hands-off storytelling approach by
keeping lots of information inside
quests and small world details but it
would make sure that no player slips
through the cracks of the main focus the
narrative of the game at the end of the
day maybe this design was completely
intentional by Yoko taro
and if so I respect that but I think it
was the wrong design choice I guess I
feel that the hands-off approach was
applied just a little too strongly for a
narrative based game for most people it
didn't make a difference which means
even if this is a flaw it isn't too big
of one on the large scale but still
cleaning this mechanic up can make the
game that much better which at the end
of the day is what we would all want for
games to keep getting better and I would
like to reiterate that nee automata
definitely did achieve this it has
continued the tradition of raising the
bar for great video games and all those
involved in making it should be very
proud this video just showed my single
biggest gripe with it and with so many
people already heaping on praise for the
game I thought it made sense to offer up
some criticism let me know what you guys
think about automata and Robby and Yoko
Tardos design choices I'd like to thank
the youtuber Valkyrie Aurora for videos
on near which are the ones I mentioned
that helped me make the connection
between automata and the souls series
and see automata in a more sympathetic
light this video actually shows my views
in the most positive they've been in
since I finished the game if you're
interested in automata or any of the
rest of its series she has a lot of good
videos on it I may make some more
automata videos but we'll see how people
like this one and how much
more I have to say thank you for
watching and have the swaggiest of days